many Americans in their 20s and 30s may
have given up on the dream of
homeownership a new survey finds nearly
nine million Millennials expect to be
permanent renters that's up more than a
million people from a year ago nearly
half a millennial renters say they have
not saved a dime for a down payment to
buy a home CBS News business financial
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here to
explain why and what this means for the
housing market what is the biggest
hurdle or what are the biggest hurdles
that you see facing Millennials when it
comes to homeownership you know we used
to say oh they're different than us
different generation and actually it's
an old school thing they want to buy
homes but the homes they're seeking are
not affordable yeah so many of them
don't have high enough pay they are
burdened with so much student loan debt
one point six trillion dollars
outstanding of student loan debt so lack
of affordability this debt you can
understand why some really feel locked
out of the housing are there fewer
affordable homes on the market now yeah
well this is a very interesting thing
because after the financial crisis what
we know is there was a ton of homes out
there right a lot of foreclosed homes
well a bunch of investors in private
equity firms gobbled up all that
inventory they took those homes off the
market and they turn them into rentals
which is what people wanted but those
homes actually have remained permanently
off the market we also know that many
older Americans are actually what
they're calling aging in place they're
not moving out of their big house where
they raise their families they're
sticking around last year we have a
statistic just out yesterday from the
Census Bureau where we have just nine
point eight percent of Americans moving
that is the lowest level of people
moving since 1947 so homes are just not
abundant right now meanwhile many
millions are moving from the country to
the city looking for places to stay
there aren't that many of them why are
particularly get easily difficult this
is obvious with the coasts right we know
that there are tons of people flocking
to places like New York and San
Francisco and in those in LA and those
areas we see a real lack of
affordability but some of the most
the strange thing I guess of the cities
that that pop up on the list where
people say I really don't think I'm ever
gonna own Detroit and st. Louis also on
that list and so when you look San Jose
San Francisco New York and LA that makes
sense
Detroit st. Louis and Portland Oregon
maybe not as much and I think this has a
lot to do with people just not making
enough money that lack of affordability
where's the tipping point when you know
whether it's smarter to rent or buy you
know such a boring old certified
financial planner that I'm gonna tell
you that you've got to run the numbers
because look you may be a millennial in
Detroit and be able to afford to own a
home but you do have to start with what
can I afford and not just how much is
this mortgage the principal the interest
excuse me in the taxes but also what
about the upkeep of a home 1 to 3
percent of that purchase price every
year I'm a renter but I would love to
buy home one day when you look at that
number 20 percent is what you they tell
you is that always the case or what's
your advice with that if you don't have
the 20% should you not even not gonna be
a good news no not gonna give you a
little bit of the good news bad news the
good news is that if you've got a steady
job you probably can get away with
putting down less than 20% but you will
be paying private mortgage insurance and
that can be anywhere from 0.3 to over 1%
of the total loan value and that means
that you really have this extra part of
your payment you also have to be very
careful you've got to monitor the rules
of your particular private mortgage
insurance because as soon as you get to
80 percent equity you want to go back to
the lender and say hey lift that PMI off
my loan amount so I can actually have
for your cash but look buying and
renting there really is a distinction it
also in terms of flexibility over being
a renter opportunity but we know that
people like to mess so we don't want to
turn our I don't want to say that buying
is a terrible deal I just think that
many people you should be comfortable
renting until it feels okay for you
financially it's big change though and
the way people live oh yes absolutely
right just left before us Joe thank you
very much